PURNIMA KOCHIKAR: It's
my distinct pleasure
to introduce Arianna Huffington,
journalist extraordinaire,
founder of Huff Post--
I sort of start and end my
day on Huff Post sometimes,
I feel--
author of 15 bestselling books,
including, most recently,
"The Sleep Revolution,"
"Time" magazine's 100
most influential, "Forbes"
most powerful women,
board member to Uber, Onex,
Global Citizen, Just Capital.
It feels super hard driving.
And it feels like,
oh, my god, how do you
manage all of this in 24 hours?
And yet we find ourselves
here talking about her latest
venture, which she
founded in 2016,
called Thrive Global, a
corporate and consumer
well-being and
productivity platform
to help us change the
way we work and live.
Welcome, Arianna.
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON:
Thank you so much.
PURNIMA KOCHIKAR: Where does
that hard-charging "Forbes"
most powerful, "Time's"
100 most influential
get to talking about sleep?
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON: Well,
this is a fantastic question
to start with.
Because it's at the heart
of everything we're doing
at Thrive, which is ending the
delusion that we've been living
under, really, since the
first Industrial Revolution--
so for decades--
that, in order to
succeed, in order
to achieve amazing things
like everybody here is doing,
we need to be always on.
We need to never stop,
to unplug, and recharge.
And what is interesting
about that is that we now
have overwhelming data--
scientific findings that prove
that the opposite is true--
that, in fact, when we
take time to recharge
we operate from a deeper, more
productive, more effective,
more creative part of ourselves,
and we achieve much more
in a more sustainable way.
And what is
interesting-- you know,
you and I come from
ancient civilizations--
India and ancient
Greece knew that.
So if you go back to the
ancient wisdom of our cultures,
they knew that.
As you know, India is
my favorite country.
I started at Santiniketan
University when I was 17.
And the Bhagavad Gita
makes it very clear
that there is that higher
life where you actually
operate from resources that,
otherwise, you don't even
know you have.
PURNIMA KOCHIKAR: But somewhere,
despite being in Santiniketan
when you were 17, I
think I heard something
about hitting a head on a desk--
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON: Exactly.
PURNIMA KOCHIKAR: --that
caused this awakening.
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON: Absolutely.
I kind of basically bought
into the collective delusion,
which is really hard
to avoid if you're
a type A personality like
everybody here is, I'm sure,
and everybody on stage.
Let's admit it.
So I absolutely
bought into all that.
And so two years into
building The Huffington Post,
being a divorced mother of
two teenage daughters, which
has its own problems attached,
I collapsed from burnout,
sleep deprivation, exhaustion.
I hit my head on my
desk, broke my cheekbone.
And that was really the
beginning of my new awakening
that led to launching
Thrive and being here.
PURNIMA KOCHIKAR:
How long did it
take from that awakening to
really change habits and be
that person who
now has bestselling
books on this topic?
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON: So I'm
a kind of research freak.
So I started
studying everything,
delving into the latest science.
And the entire Thrive
Global platform
is based on the
scientific knowledge
that we grow and change
through micro-steps.
It doesn't happen overnight.
It's small, incremental,
daily changes.
So that's what happened with
me in every aspect of life,
from the obvious--
sleep and meditation-- but also,
what's happening in our minds.
Because very often, it's what
I call the obnoxious roommate
living in our head-- you
know, that negative voice.
We women have it worse, guys--
self-doubt and
questioning everything
that we need to address.
So doing all that eliminates
of the energy leaks.
So it makes more
energy available to us
to simply get things done and
achieve groundbreaking things.
PURNIMA KOCHIKAR:
OK, so here you
are with your awakening
and your research,
and you're armed with it.
But you're starting a company
like a lot of folks here--
small companies which
are fast growth.
Did it worry you that maybe
this is not good for business,
that this is good
for the person,
that the company may
need to be hard-charging?
How do the business
leaders in this room
make a change within
their organizations?
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON:
So being hard-charging
is absolutely the necessary
way to get anything done.
Yardley Pohl, who
is here, who heads
product for Thrive
Global, and I call
it having a high metabolism.
We don't want to hire
anybody who does not
have a high metabolism.
We don't want to hire anybody
who is not hard-charging.
And at the beginning,
there are some people
who thought, oh, this
company is about thriving.
I can join and chill
under a mango tree.
No, no.
Wrong company.
No.
We just believe and we
have the data to prove it--
when I say believe, it's
not really the right word--
that when hard-charging
individuals then take some time
to unplug and recharge,
they are going
to be much more effective when
they return hard-charging.
And that's really the key.
And you know that.
I'm so happy to be speaking
to an audience which
is so much about
getting things done,
achieving, and
knowing that you need
to focus to be able to do that.
And I think what
is key here is also
our relationship
with technology.
Because we are all
a little addicted.
I see a few people who can't
stop looking at their phones.
Let me just tell you something.
That's perfectly fine.
But don't fool
yourself into thinking
you are also listening to us.
You are making a choice that
clearing emails or texts
right now is more important.
I totally get it.
We are not offended.
I just want to make it clear
that multitasking is a myth.
You cannot do two things at
once that involve mental energy.
Yeah, you can wash the dishes
and listen to a podcast.
But you can't do two things
that require cognitive energy.
That's why, at Thrive Global,
we don't allow devices
during meetings.
Because you know
these incredibly
long and unproductive when
everybody, the minute there
is a moment of boredom,
goes to their phone.
They pretend that
they are taking notes.
But you know they're not.
So we basically say, listen,
if you have something
more important to do, go do it.
If you're here, just
be 100% present.
And so there's an
enormous amount of stuff
that we can bring
to our companies
to be able to be hard-charging
in a sustainable way.
Building a company
is not a sprint.
It's a marathon.
So we need to do it
for the long haul.
PURNIMA KOCHIKAR: You
have coined these two
kind of very interesting terms.
You describe 2017 as the year
of the great awakening, where
we became aware of what
technology is doing to us,
and 2018 as the great reckoning.
What's happening?
How did we get here?
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON:
Well, as you know,
everybody here is involved
in building great products
or running great companies.
So until 2017,
speaking generally,
we were completely
enthralled with technology.
We did not really look at
the unintended consequences.
There was a certain kind of
triumphalism around tech.
2017 was the year
of great awakening,
when we also saw that,
even though there
is so much to celebrate around
the role of tech in our lives,
there are also
unintended consequences.
And they have to do largely
with the way technology is
infringing on our humanity.
So we need to establish
rules of the road.
We need to establish
sacred boundaries.
And I love "take, not harm,"
the great Buddhist monk line.
But it has never been easier
to run away from ourselves.
PURNIMA KOCHIKAR: That's kind
of a really interesting thing
to talk about.
Because this morning,
I talked about what
we are doing in Digital
Wellbeing Most of the platforms
have announced some investments.
We are giving users more
control over their tech.
And we're expecting users
to choose what they can
and how much they use.
Are we doing enough?
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON:
Well, first of all,
I think the launch of Digital
Wellbeing was fantastic.
I was there applauding.
I loved seeing your CEO in
front of a screen that said
"JOMO- the joy of missing out."
I think it was one of
those great moments in tech
when a great tech
leader acknowledges
the responsibility of tech
to actually produce products
that help people manage their
relationship with technology
in a way that improves the
quality of their lives.
And what I love about
that is that it is clearly
good for business, also.
Because in the end,
if your consumers
recognize that you are
adding value to their lives,
their loyalty will
only increase.
I think this is an
ongoing pursuit.
I don't think there will ever
be a day when we can say,
we've done enough, we are done.
I think, as Apple showed,
bringing screen time on iOS,
which helps you manage your
relationship with technology,
more and more tech companies
now are entering the field.
Thrive launched an
app for Android.
So anybody here on
Android can download it.
It's called the Thrive app.
And it can help you put
your phone in Thrive mode.
Let's say you're having
dinner with your children
or your girlfriend
or your boyfriend
and you don't want
to be distracted.
If I text you, I get a text
back, you are in Thrive mode
until such-and-such
a time, which I love,
because it also changes
the cultural norm.
Right now, we sort of
congratulate people
for being always on, for
answering texts immediately.
We need to change that.
We need people to
say, hey, Arianna
has a real sense of priority.
She really takes some time
to be undistracted when she's
doing something that matters.
And the other
thing the app does,
it gives you a
dashboard everyday
of your social media, game,
and general app consumption.
And it can help you set
limits if you so desire.
Let's say the app shows that you
spend two hours on Instagram.
And it asks you if
you want to limit it.
If you say, yes, I want to
spend an hour and a half,
it will give you a notification
so that, in an hour and a half,
it cuts you out.
Tough love.
So Apple has put it on
the operating system
for iOS users, which is great.
They don't have the Thrive mode,
but they have everything else.
So again, I think
tech for good, tech
that helps us improve
the quality of our lives
is just a great opportunity
for any developers in the room
to pursue in the future.
PURNIMA KOCHIKAR: And yet I'm
sure everybody sitting here
are measuring, what's
my engagement metric?
How many minutes is
somebody spending in my app?
It feels a little
scary that people are
going to get out of their app.
These folks in this
room, how should they
measure what's success?
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON: Absolutely.
We're all going to be
measuring consumer engagement.
At Thrive, obviously, we
measure consumer engagement
on our media platform, on our
different social platforms.
The question is, what are
they doing while they're
engaging with you?
Is what they are doing while
they're engaging with you
improving their life or
diminishing their life?
And also, are you
becoming so addictive
that other parts of their
lives are suffering--
their relationships
with their loved ones,
their relationship
with themselves?
These are the questions to ask.
And the one thing
I can guarantee
is that these things are not
in opposition to your business
metrics.
Because in the
end, I'm convinced
that the people will win the
future are the people who
add value to consumers'
lives, often ahead
of what consumers
think they need.
One of my favorite
marketing stories
is Henry Ford, who said, if
I had asked my customers what
they wanted, they would have
told me "a faster horse."
Instead, I gave them a car.
So we all sometimes
give consumers
something they may not
even fully know they want.
But if it improves
their lives, that's
an incredible source of loyalty.
PURNIMA KOCHIKAR: That leads
us really well into something.
You and I just caught up
a couple of minutes ago,
and you said, how about teaching
empathy and other things
through apps and games?
And you have talked a lot
about human-centered design.
Can you talk a little
bit about that?
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON: Yes,
we are all fascinated
with AI and the growth of AI.
And Kai-Fu Lee recently
wrote a very interesting book
predicting that 2/3 of jobs are
going to be eliminated by AI.
But the jobs that are
going to be at a premium
are jobs that require
purely human qualities,
like creativity, empathy,
compassion, love.
These are the qualities that
we humans are unbeaten at.
So in the war for talent,
these are the qualities that
are going to be at a premium.
So how do we cultivate them?
So my kind of plead with
anybody here who's a developer
is to build a product that
cultivate human empathy.
And I think this is going
to be an incredible business
opportunity.
Because empathy is going to be a
greater and greater requirement
for any interactions.
In companies, in order to
build successful teams,
you need human
beings who know how
to empathize with each other.
So if you can create games
that can teach empathy,
whether it's to kindergartners
or to people at any age,
it would be an
incredible benefit.
And if anybody has any such
idea, please let me know.
Because we would love to help
support it, help fund it,
help amplify it.
Basically, we are in
the business not just
of building our own company,
but helping that whole ecosystem
that produces tech
for good that improves
the quality of our lives.
PURNIMA KOCHIKAR: And taking
that one step further, one way,
I suppose, to be empathetic is
to respect your user's time.
And you've also
talked about building
more respectful experiences.
How do you know you're
respecting your user's time?
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON: The
question is, is your user
using your app or your game
or whatever intentionally?
Or are they just using
it in a compulsive way,
without getting any
benefit at the end of it?
You know when you have that
feeling of, oh, my god,
I can't believe I spent 40
minutes on "Candy Crush?"
And you have that kind
of sinking feeling.
Well, that's not something
you want associated
with your program, long-term.
Short-term, you may
get a benefit from it.
But I think we may not have
superhero movies for coders
and developers, but
I think maybe you
should make some superhero
movies for coders
and developers who
are actually producing
products that are helping
people invest their time well.
Because that's all we have.
I've always been
fascinated by philosophy
and the meaning of life, ever
since I was a little girl.
And in the end, how we spend our
time is how we spend our life.
It's the cumulative result
of all these daily decisions
we make.
PURNIMA KOCHIKAR: I love that.
How we spend our time is
how we spend our life.
So maybe we started with
your great awakening
by literally hitting
your head on a table,
and you went into it
trying to figure out
what everybody can do from
a business responsibility
perspective.
I want to bring it back to you.
This has been an
amazing journey.
First of all, thank
you for applying
your incredible journalistic
mindset to this problem.
It's been an incredible
journey in learning this.
What were the surprises
for you, individually,
in getting to this place?
Did you slip off the
bandwagon, as they say,
and did you have
to climb back in?
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON: Well, I feel
so passionate about this topic
that I left the Huffington Post
two years ago to launch Thrive.
And frankly, I never, ever
thought I would do that.
Because Huff Post was
like a third child--
you know, two daughters
and Huff Post.
But I wanted to go beyond
just writing and speaking
about these topics
and actually do
something that helps
people go from perhaps
knowing what they want to
do to actually doing it.
And what brought me to
journalism at the beginning
was that desire we all have
to reduce human suffering.
And there is a lot of human
suffering in the world that we
cannot really easily reduce--
when you I read the stories
of refugee children,
or children separated
from their parents,
or violence everywhere.
But this is an incredible
cause of human suffering
that we can change simply
by changing beliefs.
Because once you
eliminate the belief,
which is unbelievably prevalent,
that all successful people
do it by being always
on and sacrificing
everything else to that cause--
once you eliminate
that delusion,
we are going to be eliminating
an incredible cause of disease,
of bad decisions, and
unnecessary mental health
problems.
So that's an incredible cause.
And that's really the very
ambitious cause of Thrive.
And we do it through our
work with corporations,
and we do it through
the media platform.
But what we have found is
that the most effective thing
on the media platform is
not the data we collect.
We collect all the latest
science on these topics.
But what moves
hearts and minds is
the stories of very successful
people in the arena who
are living their
lives differently
as a result of their own
wake-up calls or epiphanies,
all very different, but
having a similar point
to my own epiphany.
And actually, one
of your colleagues,
Philipp Schindler, the chief
business officer at Google,
had his own moment of epiphany
that he wrote about on Thrive,
which I love, which was
that he came from a trip,
and he has young children,
and he told his children,
Daddy is taking you
to the playground.
And his five-year-old
said to him, oh, no,
can't the babysitter take us?
And he asked why.
And his son said, because
when you're in the playground,
you're always on your phone.
So that was his moment of
epiphany, when he decided,
I'm busy.
I travel a lot.
When I'm going to
be with my children,
I'm going to be
with my children.
And I'm not going
to be on my phone.
And then after he
wrote about it,
he told me what an impact
it had in his own org.
And I know it had an
incredible impact among people
who simply admired him.
People need permission to
make these little changes.
Because there is
a fear that, if I
get my foot off the gas
for even five minutes,
I'm not going to
be able to succeed.
It's a very deep-seated fear.
And so when we
collect the stories
of very successful people--
Jeff Bezos wrote
on Thrive that he
sleeps for eight hours a
night because he says it
improves his decision-making.
And he analyzed his
decision-making.
And he wrote that, when
he sleeps for less,
his decision-making is
5% to 20% less good.
And the piece went crazy viral.
And so we bring in
people in the arena
and have them write about what
makes them most effective.
I like to out very
successful people
and the good things they do.
Because we've heard so much
about very successful people
bragging.
OK, the other extreme,
which is a teachable moment,
is Elon Musk.
He started a company
with this delusionary
believe that he has to
do everything himself.
He has to sleep under his desk.
He cannot see his children.
But we see the result of that.
We see that he tweets in
the middle of the night
that he got the funding
to take Tesla private,
which was not true, which
led to an SEC investigation,
which led to him having
to step down as chairman
and being fined $20 million--
not a very good decision.
I'm saying that
I love Elon Musk.
I think he's brilliant
and a great visionary.
But he's also doing an
incredible service now
by demonstrating the delusion
of the way he is working.
And that may be just an
incredible gift to humanity.
I wrote an open
letter to him saying
all that out-- saying,
the way you are working
is unscientific.
You know, you claim to
really have developed,
and you have a new way to
manage energy to for cars.
What about managing
energy for humanity?
And that's why this is
such an exciting time.
PURNIMA KOCHIKAR:
Well, no wonder
you're so quotable--
managing energies for cars
versus managing
energies for humanity.
The meme in the valley, of
which you are well aware,
is that sleep is for the weak.
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON: Yes.
PURNIMA KOCHIKAR: And
you have picked that
as your cornerstone
of well-being.
Can you talk about why sleep?
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON:
Yeah, we actually
have eight pathways broken
down into micro-steps,
and sleep is one.
The reason why there is
so much focus on sleep
is because, for so many decades,
it's been so dismissed and held
in contempt.
And yet all the science
makes it very clear
that it's the
foundation of health--
not just of our physical
health, but our brain health.
And a lot of that
research was done
nearby here at Stanford, where
the first scientific sleep
center was founded,
only in 1970.
So it's a relatively
young science.
But we now see that the way our
culture has been contemptuous
of sleep has actually led to
tremendous problems and bad
decisions and health outcomes,
including heart disease,
diabetes, Alzheimer's.
Because the bottom line
is that, unless you
have a genetic mutation--
and 1% to 1 and 1/2%
the population does--
and you don't need
a lot of sleep--
I'm sure there are people here
who don't, and that's great.
And you know it.
You can also be tested.
But I know that, if I have
three or four hours sleep,
it's not enough.
So the majority of us
need seven to nine hours.
I'm an eight-hour girl.
And when I get my eight
hours, it's like, bring it on.
Whatever the challenge,
I can handle it.
And also, I'm not robbed
of the joy of life.
One of the things that I know--
when I'm sleep-deprived, I
can still be transactional.
We can still go through
the motions of our day.
But something is missing.
And I don't want
that spark to miss.
Because as far as
we know, that's
our only life,
although reincarnation
is a very good possibility.
And I don't want to
just get things done.
I want to experience the joy
and the gratitude of the fact
that I'm doing something
I love and I believe in
and what a blessing that is.
PURNIMA KOCHIKAR: Wow.
OK.
So given that this is
where you find yourself,
what's next for you?
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON:
So what's next?
As you know, Thrive Global
is the name of the company,
not just because we
could get the URL.
[LAUGHS] This is
a global crisis,
and the solution is global.
So our first international
launch was in India.
We launched in partnership
with "The Times of India."
And I love what
we are doing there
in the middle of what is
a mental health, crisis,
especially among millennials,
who are particularly addicted
to their phones.
We launched in my
homeland, in Greece.
And we launched in Australia.
We are going to China.
And we are launching
around the world.
And in every big culture,
we are customizing
what we are offering with
the culture of the country.
Because there is such amazing
wisdom in India, in China,
in Japan.
And I think it's so important
to bring everything we're doing
and integrate it with the
culture and the wisdom
of the region.
And for me, I'm just so
incredibly grateful when people
write and tell their stories.
So I want to invite you
to tell your stories.
Because that's how we
learn from each other.
Whether it's stories of wake-up
calls, like mine or Philipp
Schindler's, or whether they're
stories of your own life hacks
and what you do to
be most effective,
please share them
with the world.
It's just an incredible service.
And also, Yardley
would not forgive me
if I didn't say
that we are hiring.
[LAUGHTER]
We have opened an
office in San Francisco.
Our headquarters is in New York.
And we really want to grow
our product and engineering
team very fast, because we
have so many projects in line.
And for the women
in the room, I'm
also thrilled to say that we
have a head of product who
is a woman in Yardley and a CTO
in Cheryl Porro, who is also
a woman, who just joined
us from Salesforce.
So I'm very happy
to recruit men.
Let me make that very clear.
But I also think
it's an amazing time
to be a woman in
product and engineering.
Look at you.
And it's great to
be building a team
that we hope is going to add a
lot of value to people's lives.
PURNIMA KOCHIKAR: Well, you
have some super creative people.
I know you're trying
to recruit them.
But besides recruiting
them, if there's one message
you want to leave them
with, what would that be?
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON:
So my message
is that you are the
architects of the future.
And what you choose
to do and where
you choose to put
your own creativity
and your own imagination is
going to change the world.
So it's really incredibly
important, whether you're
running businesses or developing
or coding or anything at all,
this is a pivotal moment.
The decisions we make everyday,
the products we build,
the businesses we build are
going to affect dramatically
the way we live and
the world we create.
And I'm not at all
worried about AI.
Because AI may become
more intelligent than we
are, but it will never
become more loving,
more compassionate, more
empathetic, or more creative.
That's our competitive edge.
Let's cultivate it.
PURNIMA KOCHIKAR: Wow.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you so much for sharing
your wisdom with us today.
I hope every one of
us will take this.
At least for me, I think
that I will remember,
am I transacting
or am I actually
feeling the joy of what I
am doing with gratitude?
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON: And can
you please write about it?
PURNIMA KOCHIKAR: Yes.
[LAUGHS] Yes, I will.
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON: OK.
She said that in front
of many witnesses.
So we are going to
hold her accountable.
And what was it like
having here, on stage,
for 30 minutes, two
women with accents?
[APPLAUSE]
PURNIMA KOCHIKAR: All right.
With that, give Arianna
a very, very big hand.
[APPLAUSE]